to sync your Windows Live calendar
you'll need to get your unique calendar
URL here's how to do it go to your
Windows Live calendar and select the
calendar you want to sync from under
share in the share settings check the
box for send friends of you only link to
your calendar click import into another
calendar application under the detail
section copy the URL from the
popup now go to management in your tungl
me account select synced from the menu
and click add new calendar and contact
sync Source choose Windows Live from the
popup name your calendar and paste in
the URL you copied from Windows Live
click add
Source your Windows Live calendar is now
synced note that the tungle me sync with
Windows Live is readon that means you'll
be able to see your Windows Live Events
in in tungl me and your availability
will be updated as you add new events to
your Windows Live calendar but tungl me
will not be able to add new events
booked through tungl me to your Windows
Live calendar